[Music]
it impressive but illegal news so
limited by what's the bails baby gender
in all cat they want to know I'm sorry
what the bail
baby gender it will be announced soon
hopefully maybe to be born and then we
find some no and then we're going to
take the area and no one knows you're
the judge reveal just gonna rip it off
the paper buddy do it what am I supposed
to be funny yeah this is not your child
supposed to be real this is my own
that's what they do when they announced
a new car he'll to pull that silk sheet
over see that taint on genital yeah but
how do you make this girl she stick
superglue no which is really big so it
cascades over the entire table obviously
don't know science yeah I got to get the
baby
that's messed up prisoners built - she
seized from parts hid them in the
ceiling and used them to do more crimes
God daddies was a genius minute these
fools were keep stirring hard drives and
[ __ ] motherboard machines [ __ ] fit
a damn desktop in your bubble hilarious
crazy you're the [ __ ] RAM stick to
our hello Jackie with all these micro
chain oh dude that rectum is torn the
[ __ ] up right bro I got four CPUs and
Emma I know it sounds like it sounds
like goodbye definitely I like that kind
of crime yet time everybody to flop it
is their sloppiness Swapna doesn't even
have a [ __ ] lot anymore
oh I miss floppy discs so they have to
build a computer and then they also have
to get on the Wi-Fi so that to hack the
coder or don't tell me the prison system
so stupid that anybody could just get on
the wire you Wi-Fi a bunch of college
students are just kicking it around the
[ __ ] prison
okay so these two Ohio inmates they were
working in like some sort of like
program where they're able to
disassemble like computer parts Oh
technology Oh
and so they
they were hiding the parts where they
could coming back into where they have
their selves and so they are building
these two computers in a closet area and
I can they call it a training closet
so I'm not sure what that exactly means
but they will be a trainer but for what
penetration it doesn't rip that's like
shaming really guys kind of all of these
that are said a baby rip in general
that's but that's a that's a me know
what the [ __ ] wrong with you no
seriously man but all over the world are
having their feelings hurt okay I'm
sorry but we should why should she go
Bailey I'm gonna continue I'm sorry
goodness me I'm sorry all the potholes
and the water burgers I hope not there's
a lot of poo poo it's good gross
okay so yes so they built these two
computers and they were actually I don't
I'm not sure for how long they've had it
they were getting away with it for a
while because the president didn't catch
on to this until they switch their
security system languish in a network
they switched whatever they were using
before and then so this new system that
they were using games like they sent
them an email alert saying that there
was a computer in their network that had
exceeded its internet threshold ooh it
was like that porno they were doing a
lot of [ __ ] or they're on Facebook they
were they were downloading porn they
were up she just screamed it they were
able to get access to all the inmates
there and all their information like
their social security cards Zoomers days
where they live like college it and so
they use other inmates for credit card
fraud exactly I knew it true for that so
they were doing that and they were also
planning but they're in jail they're not
going to know if there's identity theft
set up a bunch of credit card
[ __ ] you have to [ __ ] your ass up
everybody finds out crazy you [ __ ] up
my already [ __ ] up credible
no idea maybe time in your life when you
want to tell those who haven't saw your
building should anyone yes sir they were
they were doing that they were also
planning a tax fraud scheme we're using
like the social security numbers there
is somehow able to manipulate the system
through hacking is to get the refunds to
be sent to them
Wow how smart these [ __ ] like
Asian brothers or something what is this
uh Danny and [ __ ] Benny Ching I know
you want another name yes Adam Johnson
and Scott Briggs told you oh no it's
like these guys yeah yeah you know these
[ __ ] genius if we stole their
identities and then we had the tax
returns set to us about not only that
they were downloading porn they're also
reading articles on how to manufacture
drugs and weapons and researching about
Mountain Dew ingredients so productive a
lot they did a lot and they also made
passes to access unauthorized areas
within the prison or the positive prison
[ __ ] caught on so so apparently their
warden at the time knew about this oh
they were getting paid off I don't know
I don't know three is everything is
still being investigated right now what
do they go to jail for forty like a
cyber crime I want to know that too I
don't know yeah those are really smart
they're really really really intelligent
because I wouldn't do that
I love how like they have all these like
sophisticated things going on but no
matter what a man is a man and you need
a corner you need this point no matter
how intelligent you need this point for
sure like even if I got to build the
computer I would have just gotten far as
just watching porn mmm that would have
been like what I just talked to you guys
on group me and you know [ __ ] will
you know check my emails watch a little
porn go to jail I just throughout group
me I'll just constantly send you porn
here you go Joe yeah probably the only
thing that flag the whole system to our
point was downloading of the porn I like
if they just ate underneath the radar
and I don't thinking you know or else
you probably learn too much bandwidth
yeah and they were also so what they
would do they would download porn music
newly released movies and TV not to have
the DVD questions like USB Drive and
they would sell it to other inmates
which makes me think like hiding and
retrieve that information that I view it
looking just upload it to USB to go to
the jail library and they can watch the
latest movie on Netflix so they're
saying that at this prison there'd be a
lot of periods of time where they don't
really supervisor than me or anything
well that's why they need all that porn
and movies it's their board I think if I
owned a prison I for sure would give
them like spank material because I need
them to relax yeah but they're but
they're in prison very worried but it's
still biological that's like enough to
feed them right so if you have to give a
meal you might as all that I'm frickin
bust a nut every day always give them
like mandatory pocket [ __ ] days yeah
because if they're like all testosterone
DUP and they're not relaxing they're
gonna fight the guards and each other
and cuz you can't return character
assist after you come
yep try it try to get a UFC fighter
before they go into the ring have them
[ __ ] come right before they step on
stage into to get - nuh-uh - Barnea
spice in the world I know I think that
well do I let's just cuddle homey I know
I just want that post come cuddle to be
around one oh yeah yeah that [ __ ]
post come map you know yeah so this is
where they were hiding the computer and
they connected to the the system's
network and so oh that's what a
defibrillator where equalities poor is
done it's a lot of [ __ ] key string
shouldn't CIA like just hire them right
now I would not savages or follow
Facebook outside a bail and I hire them
guys they were making money while
they're in prison yeah they were they
had Bitcoin wallet like account they had
a stripe account they had what else bank
accounts credit cards everything
on their productive I'm really proud of
them I want to be as smart as them can I
can abuse more losing your smarting
you're always yeah but I want to be
fraudulent smart why because you could
take that type of mentality and put it
to businesses mm-hmm yep
I'm too lazy for that do we know quite a
few people now there were the biggest
scumbags on earth that develop great
businesses yep to the Machine never been
even tomorrow yeah because they were
asking like why did you not immediately
report this to the Ohio State Highway
Patrol and the Ohio Inspector General as
required by state policy and when they
asked him that he just responded I don't
have an answer at all and have an answer
for you okay then he later online he
actually resigned after being questioned
like that he got pressured I feel like
he was getting he was getting hooked up
or what Phil's blackmail blackmail oh
like if you don't do this well I got
your information I gotta make it like a
bat for you then it's no blame
everything on ask a little sister that's
crazy news of blackmail
hello JK news fans now I know you want
to be a part of our videos and you know
how you do that you go to the [ __ ]
link below and use [ __ ] submit some
articles other than that go check out
our videos up here hell yeah
[Music]